nous avons déjà rejeté l'article 1er
l'article 2 de cette réforme dans la
nuit de mardi à mercredi et le 26 avril
lors du vote solennel les députés
républicains je vous l'annoncé vous le
confirme votre ont contre ce projet de
loi constitutionnelle ce qui veut dire
donc il n'y aura pas congrès ça c'est au
président de la république la réforme de
la constitution garde mais j'imagine
qu'il n'y aura pas de majorité pour
affaiblir l'état car en fait c'est ça la
question de fond c'est une révision
constitutionnelle qui loin de renforcer
l'état de droit
de mon point de vue la faiblesse d'une
réforme incomplète qui s'adresse à une
partie d'un tout qui devrait être
réformé que vous autour d'eux